[Music]
if I've been asked that question ever
been asked the question about how I got
interesting science quite a bit I think
it is just my education system it's hard
to say I mean my dad was an engineer and
my mother was a high school teacher and
so I think education was very big for
both of them so they did take us to
things like the Toronto Science Center
and they did take us to these Audubon
lectures about birds and I have to say I
did not spark any interest in birds with
me so I told but not everybody gets
raised by the parents that are as
interested in education and and studies
that way but I think it's mostly because
in school I did very well in math and
science and I I was one of those kids
who thought science class was fun and
most people don't so I don't know why I
just did
[Music]
I had in high school I think I had very
good science teachers there was mrs.
Bowman in grade 9 whose husband was a
chemistry professor and she would spent
her summers in her husband's lab
learning the latest in chemistry so I
had her for grade 9 science and she
would like to have things exploding in
the front of her room and she was
wonderful in a lot of ways I had her
again for grade 12 chemistry and she
brought in chocolate bars for us one
test B I had to miss because I was in
the high school band and we'd gone to
England during the one test and so she
just she's before you start you must
have your brain working and so she gave
us each a chocolate bar to get us a
brain working but also I must say Jim
Forsyth was my physics teacher in grade
13 and I was in his homeroom for the
entire five years of high school so I
saw it in the physics room every morning
to start the school day and he also he
also has long put me on I'm on I've been
for 20 years on my high school wall of
fame and it was my high school physics
teacher that did that for me
[Music]
so my mother was raised in a small
Canadian farm town she was raised on a
farm she had an older brother and an
older sister now the brother inherited
the farm and did not go to university
but the two girls and and this was back
in the 1940s were both sent to
university the oldest one had thought
about going into medicine but switched
into nursing and my mother wanted to go
into maths and Sciences that's what she
was good at but before her sister went
ahead of her and my mother got advised
that as a female she would find going
into the science it's very hard and that
she would be better served by going into
the arts so my mother listened to these
people because coming from a town of
1,000 she just felt overwhelmed about
the idea and so she chose to go then
into the arts and then regretted it ever
asked him so again I was raised by a
very strong woman who made it clear that
she wished she had followed her heart
and soul and not listen to everybody
else
I think Marie Curie is just one of those
icons that you hear about so I can't
possibly tell you when I would have
first heard of her gay purred my I
didn't even know was a woman when I
cited her in my thesis I just knew of
you know
JP Myers work and it is very funny that
I actually said he and my thesis that's
how uneducated I am and one of the
people reading the theorist who had
helped me at the end he Joe Everly
stroked it off and said Donna shame on
you
[Music]
I think since Maria gave it Meyer has
won that there's many more women in
science then than when she was there
right I think the fact that she did not
get a paying job as a scientist until I
think the 1950s which is when she did
her Nobel prize-winning work is amazing
right so I've been paid all along I
never had a female professor not as an
undergrad not as a grad student and now
there are six of us I believe in my
department of 40 so that's still only
you know 15% it's it's not as high as it
should be but the fact that there are
even six women instead of zero is quite
a change so I think things are changing
for women all the time
certainly I grew up in the 70s and we
were all about women's lib and I
remember being told over and over again
women you can do anything
so never entered my mind that I couldn't
[Music]
I think everybody in the world should be
told that do what you love and what you
think you're good at I don't want to
really distinguish men from women I
think there are jobs that are
stereotypically women jobs and I don't
see any reason that men shouldn't do
those I don't think women are more
caring than men and yet we hear you know
so many jobs are for women because
they're the more nurturing I think
that's just as wrong on the other side
so I think every person should be
exposed to every type of field and find
out what they're good at and everybody
should get to do what they're they're
good at on what they love to do
[Music]
now you know I feel like I have was born
under a lucky star and just life just
worked out for me and then I will tell
other women who ask me this because the
people are always wondering you know
when should you have your children and I
said no you just do what everything when
it feels right for you no there is no
one life plan that works for everybody
and because my husband and I the first
year of marriage actually lived
bicoastal so that we could both have
good jobs that got old fast and so I did
give up on on the academic track and I
took a job as a member of technical
staff and it turns out that it was
perfect for me because I had my two
children I went through my two
pregnancies on that job and I was
someone who was not just all nine months
all day long and I realized that when I
got the my first teaching job which was
right after my second child was born I
thought I could not have lectured
through those two pregnancies I could
not have stood in front of a classroom I
was so well through all those two sets
of nine months so to me my life just
keeps working out I thought maybe I was
giving up on my career but I hadn't and
someone like the University of Waterloo
was willing to hire me after four years
of being out of the academic track and
so this is what I always tell women that
you have to do what's right for you at
the time that's right for you and hope
that life works out I don't know maybe
I'm the only one born under such a lucky
star but my life seems to keep working
[Music]
I think this is the toughest thing about
being a female scientist I think once we
become 50/50 women and men then it won't
be quite the same but almost every
female scientist is married to a male
scientist male scientists can't be
married to female scientists there's not
enough of us to go around for them and
so it does bring in the two-body problem
and most couples have to find jobs
together but many other jobs exist in
almost every city whereas science jobs
only come up rarely here there and
everywhere so if you want to do the type
of sites you want to do you have to be
willing to do look worldwide and so it
is very hard for two scientists to get
jobs together and I must say my husband
followed me to Canada and took a job
with industry and it's not it wouldn't
have been his choice either and so we
took our turn as he says he's now been
22 years living in my country near my
family and with me doing the job I
wanted to do and I only was four years
in New Jersey near his family in his
country with him doing the job he wanted
to do so he kind of keeps asking when
it's his turn for me to go back and
follow him
I think diversity is a good thing
whether you're in science or in anything
again it goes along with not only should
i Vijender be exposed every person has
the right it shouldn't be a privilege it
is a right to do what you want to do and
what you are good at and I think and
I've said this before I think the world
works best if we all do what we are good
at so that no group of people should
ever be discouraged from doing what they
are good at the world works best if we
all get our opportunities and we all do
it
[Music]
so it is unusual that I am winning Nobel
Prize for my very first work I you know
it's not called it a one-hit wonder
quite a bit at the time when I give
talks and people always want to hear
about this one paper rather than my
newer work it's unusual most of the time
I think supervisors get the credit for
the work and I also think that Gerard
Maru my supervisor deserves more credit
maybe for this prize than I do because
it was his idea as the student it's my
job to take the idea and make it a
reality and so a lot of work goes into
that and people over the years have said
that the students should be credited
with the fact that although you're given
one grand idea you still have to figure
out all the other details to make the
idea work so everybody should be
rewarded I think possibly I'm one of the
people that are getting rewarded as a
student because it was an individual
project and so there were just the two
names on the paper as opposed to a large
group of names and therefore when it's a
large group of names one person
represents that group and it that one
person would have to be the supervisor
[Music]
uh I when I went to graduate school I
really went with the attitude that I
wanted to do one of the world's best
PhDs now I didn't think I was unique in
that I would think every student going
for PhD must hope to do one of the
world's great PhDs I don't think anybody
goes to do a PhD for society to say
great job I think there's many other
jobs where your parents are telling you
be a doctor be a lawyer
there are things at least in North
American culture which are held up on a
pedestal and science isn't one of them I
think you go in and do a PhD in science
because you just love it and want to do
it and if that's why you're doing it you
must want to do the best so there was
that there was a sure ARDS group were
was just a group of fabulous students
and we were all there trying to do the
best so I think we all aged each other
on we all helped each other but there
was also that competitive spirit in all
of us and we all kept we all knew the
other one was working hard so we must
work hard but as well when anybody
struggled we all figured out a way
around each person's struggle so that
they could keep moving forward so it was
even though I'm the only one getting
credited it was quite a team effort
[Music]
I think that science is a team sport I
think that you have to talk to somebody
else about it it helps you form your
ideas and it also will spark something
especially if you're at a dead end
trying to figure it out there has to
always be this conversation back and
forth whether it's from student a
supervisor student a student student
tent you know to anybody yes from
science to scientist it just helps to
talk about what you're doing
of course it's a fun it's fun to have I
particularly like having students in my
group and talking to them and trying to
get them to see it from their own
perspective and get them to the point
where they're telling me the new things
and that I can learn from them that's
that's always the goal of every
supervisor is to bring your student to
the point where they're letting you know
what I should already know and so that's
that's the joy in it
[Music]
hmm no I don't I don't I don't think I
have one piece of advice that every to
give to a student I think each of us is
unique and each of us sees it from a
different point of view and so what one
person needs another person doesn't need
I will tell you though that quite a long
time ago
before I even came to Waterloo there was
a student who was to give a talk and a
female student to give a talk and this
female student was particularly nervous
and I pointed out that I said this is
one of the challenges that I think women
have to overcome is that boys at the
time certainly were raised to have
bravado boys are raised to say look what
I did
boys whether it's through sports or
anything they are to stand up and almost
be beating themselves on a chest saying
look how good women are raised to say
quiet and demure and women are raised to
not show off and I was given this advice
early on as well I said no you must
learn that to get your PhD you must be
able to stand up and give a talk and if
you're giving a talk about your research
you are basically saying look at me this
is what I did now you don't say it in
those words but this is why it is hard
or quite often for the females to get up
and give effective talks because they
want to always be so humble about it and
they have to get over that
[Music]
so I personally think that since you
spend so many hours a day at work you
should if you have the chance I
unfortunately a lot of people have to
work just for a paycheck but a scientist
do not scientists are doing it they
could do something else that would make
them more money so I think if you don't
love what you're doing you're not going
to be doing it that's all I think and so
you can call it fun oh you could just
call that excitement or you can call it
enjoyable I call it fun
[Music]
for me the fun of science is that even
though there's a lot of hard work to get
an experiment to to happen and that you
can spend so the one that I'm being
awarded for took a year of work to get
done but there is something so exciting
about Datuk being shown on a screen or a
laser that you've been trying to
struggle to make work finally works and
you see it and laser physics is one that
you actually see happening there's all
kinds of things when you see one color
of light change to another color of
light or what have you that's exciting
to see and brand new data that you know
you have and other people don't have
this is such an exciting feeling so
that's why I just I just think it's fun
and I like building Minaya was one of my
favorite toys growing up and so building
lasers falls under that category of
feeling like a toy and that you're just
simply playing with a new thing
[Music]
well there was only one commercial
application of this laser yet and that
is cutting or machining of transparent
material so it can be glass used on a
cell phone it can be the cornea of your
eye that's the one application I was
actually quite surprised that that
started just ten years after the laser
was built usually takes quite a bit
longer from a research to a little lab
to become an actual product so I'm
surprised by that but I think going
forward the exciting one will be if we
can actually get laser acceleration to
work there's a number of people working
on laser acceleration I myself am NOT at
this point but I think if we can start
to either compete with the hospital
accelerators so that can be used for
medicine or even the large CERN that
would be the exciting one I think
no I don't feel that the work you do
should be directly applicable to society
again it falls under my idea that we
should all do what we're good at and I
don't think every one of us is good at
taking an idea out to there or knowing
what society should do but again it goes
back to the fact that scientists have to
constantly have dialogues and so it's a
whole train of people and it doesn't
matter if it's something to be used for
Society or just an application for
whatever it's a non-stop continuum of
people working together so hopefully
there's other people that are looking at
this who want to help Society and work
back to find the right things
[Music]
I think it's a shock it's a stunning
shock to be woken up to be told that you
are a Nobel Prize winner again this work
was done over 30 years ago so it's not
something that I'm living and breathing
every day that I did pulse amplification
for my PhD all those years ago so no
one's expecting in my position to win a
Nobel Prize so you get woken up at 5:00
in the morning the my husband is closer
to our landline phone that is in our
bedroom and so he answered the phone and
certainly in the middle of the night
when you get woken up it's usually a
fear thing that someone has been hurt
and so I'm saying what is it what is it
what is it and that goes they're asking
for professor Strickland so then you
kind of know that the no timer might
called professor Strickland even usually
at the University so and then you get
this it's an important call from Sweden
and then you put on hold although
actually they hung up on me but I
thought I was on hold and I'm hanging on
to Doug going it's from Sweden in his
October 2nd and I think I won the Nobel
Prize this can't really be true so
that's that's all it feels like this
can't be true
[Music]
so many things my daughter I texted four
people up before the press conference
and after I'd received the call like I
texted my brother and my sister my son
and my daughter
I knew that my brother and sister would
get it right away my sister was in
Europe so would be the daytime and my
brother wakes up I knew my two kids
would not get it right away and the
funniest one was my daughter who
unfortunately had her email hacked in
the summer before this and so when she
got the text saying I alt said this I
won the Nobel Prize she goes off mom's
phone has been hacked and even her
girlfriend called her and said
gratulations on the Nobel Prize and she
goes no my mother whose phone has been
hacked and she had to be told though
it's in the news so then she google and
she was just she was in tears screaming
at me and the phone call so that was
exciting I think at my press conference
at the University the first day my
entire department showed up and the
former chair of the department who I was
associate chair under stood up to
congratulate me on behalf of all of them
and he almost had me in tears because
they were just that's when I really
looked I think I was a deer caught in
headlights with so many cameras on me
I'd never faced such a thing before and
when I looked at each face there and
they were just all beaming at me it was
it was almost too much
[Music]
my life got turned upside down with
winning the Nobel Prize
I now realize I don't think at the time
I realized how reclusive I was and how
much I enjoy spending time all by myself
until I found out that that was not
something possible after winning a Nobel
Prize and that all of a sudden people
want my autograph or people want to take
selfies with me or you know and like I
said everybody in my department now when
they see me a big smile comes on their
face and yet it's like really because
you've known so things are very
different for me I I kind of hope they
go back to just a normal way I don't
think people can live on this heightened
excitement for very long but it's been
quite different for the last two months
[Music]
well for a scientist needs first
curiosity they need to be excited about
trying to learn something different they
have to be able to communicate well to
be a good scientist because you do have
to talk back and forth so that you get
these new ideas I think an experimental
physicist needs incredible patience and
so some students try it for a while and
realize they simply don't have the
patience to do that kind of work and
then of course things break and you have
to start again and this is it can lead
to a lot of frustration so you have to
have that kind of patience but again if
it's work you enjoy it's not as hard as
it is although it frustration is still
hard to deal with
[Music]
I'm somebody who knows what I'm trying
to get to at the end of my project and
so it doesn't matter how many hurdles
get thrown in as soon as that's another
hurdle one must figure a way around it
but that is the job of a scientist
usually the hurdles are a technical
challenge or a scientific obstacle that
you weren't expecting but then that's
what science is about if you already
knew how everything worked you wouldn't
have to do the project to start with so
each one is a new puzzle and you have to
to me I just think of it as a puzzle
rather than a problem but then I also
like to work on projects that not very
many people are working on rather than
being part of the race so this is why I
have not worked on short-pulse an
application as much I have two systems
in my lab but I look for projects that I
find really fun to do but the whole rest
of the world aren't necessarily doing
them so I don't ever feel like I'm in a
time race
[Music]
in 30 seconds might be very hard this is
a way to make sure that you can have
very intense pulses and the idea is like
I call it a laser hammer in that if you
can push on a nail with all your might
it won't go into a piece of wood but if
you hit it with a hammer quickly it goes
in and this is the idea is that we can
make our laser pulses both energetic and
short but we didn't have the hammer
inside the laser destroying the laser
which is why that it never worked before
but we could we could do it in a way
that the laser was fine and then make
the pulse short after amplification so
that it could be like a laser hammer
[Music]